[Musique]
les escales entre potes l'armée que des
potes donc on est une bande de potes
mais expliquer brièvement et simplement
ce qu'est le sionisme le sionisme
d'abord c'est le droit du peuple juif à
retourner sur sa patrie ancestrale est
devenu un état et attends attends
attends attends pas passer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien ça y est tout le monde est calme
et pour une fois ça vous concerne pas
mon cher curage des acteurs techniques
comme quoi tu vois en 5 ans s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît bien donc c'était
acteurs on sait pas très bien pourquoi
enfin bon il ya de la teinture par
poules par combler du sang devient chaud
ça va terry 29 ans
[Musique]